as most of us celebrate Christmas this
morning we're exploring the state of
Christianity as we head into a new
decade religion in the u.s. seems to be
on the decline the Pew Research Center
says 65 percent of American adults
described themselves as Christians
that's down from 12%
oh that's down 12% over the past decade
well the most reverend Michael Curry is
Presiding Bishop of the Episcopal Church
he gained international fame last year
after delivering the sermon at Prince
Harry and Meghan markle's royal wedding
we remember that Bishop curry is here
with a roll of religion and the true
meaning of Christmas good morning and
it's nice to have you back in the studio
I remember you at the wedding where you
said it's the love of two people that
bought all of us together in this room
it was such a beautiful sentiment so
let's focus on Christmas because I think
for a lot of people they think it's a
day of material gift-giving a day of
getting things that you don't want or
don't need right one of those gifting or
that you're lying for but what do you
want people to know about the real
meaning of this day you know the real
meaning of Christmas is that God made a
decision to show us what we mean to God
there's a text in the New Testament in
John's Gospel God so loved the world
that He gave His Son that His only Son
that's the key to the meaning of
Christmas first of all it's about love
secondly love is about God and thirdly
love is about giving not about taking
and if you construct a life based on
that kind of love
sacrificial unselfish that's about
giving about seeking the good and the
welfare of others sometimes even before
my own unenlightened self interest then
that kind of love is not a sweet
sentiment that kind of love is a game
changer in all human relations so how do
you encourage people to bring love into
their everyday everyday lives when
everybody so many people are so
polarized we do with the podcast you
know I mean I think in the end love
is not a sentiment it's a commitment and
therefore it's a decision it's a
commitment
it's a commission right because the
sentiment I mean look there's a
difference between loving and liking yes
liking is an emotive reaction love is a
committed response it is a decision so I
almost have to kind of have an altar
call every day and decide I'm gonna live
the most loving in the love most loving
way possible which means I'm gonna try
to be as unselfish as I can all day long
and seek your good seek your welfare
seek your well-being speak the folk when
I'm getting you know we were talking
about getting off and on airplanes I try
to speak to the flight attendants yeah
speak to the pilots speak to the persons
it no it sounds good and it sounds good
but in practice when people are really
irritating and not as accommodating and
not as loving how do you do that how do
you navigate that well honesty doesn't
hurt honesty doesn't hurt that that's
sometimes you know if someone is
inappropriate say well I appreciate what
you're saying but I can't go there right
now that's okay
loving is not soft and sentimental yeah
loving is actually seeking what is good
and what is the greatest good possible
in any situation posed to love thy
neighbor and also love your family but
right about this time of year or
sometimes the conversation sometimes
politics has been known to get into the
picture we're at a moment in this
country right now where people don't
love each other very much it would seem
how do you how do you how do you take
what you're telling us about love and
apply it to that bigger picture of the
country at large the truth is if you
want to find common ground you've got to
go to higher ground which means you've
got to have a set of values and
principles that you are committed to
living by and living by those values and
principles and applying them constantly
if you think about just in our country
the ideals the principles that this
country was founded on even when the
country didn't live it that the words
were true we hold these truths to be
self-evident that all people all men are
created equal now the fact the people
who wrote that didn't live fully into it
but it is an ideal worth striving for
everybody thinks they're going for the
ideal and the other guy's the enemy
everyone thinks they're in the right and
they're the ones on higher ground well
and I say to my friends who are
Christian just using Christians as an
example well last time I checked the one
whose name was Jesus in the 22nd chapter
of Matthew when he was asked what is the
greatest commandment in in all of God's
legal edifice he went back and reached
back to Deuteronomy and Leviticus and
said you shall love the Lord your God
with all your heart soul mind and
strength love your neighbor as yourself
on these two love of God love of
neighbor hang all the law in the
prophets that's like saying everything
that God has intended everything the
Bible is about everything the religious
Enterprise is about that is the supreme
court the supreme judgment love of God
love of neighbor if it's not about love
it's not about God you know more than
half of Americans now bishops say they
go to church just a few times a year
sure is it is it important for you to
get more people to go to church well you
know I mean you could say it's important
for business but no you know what's
really important community it is in
community one that we can often discover
God most profoundly even when community
is a headache which it often can be but
the truth is we actually need each other
Christmas can sometimes say that again
we actually need we actually need to be
reminded that who and we are at our best
when we come together
I mean God forbid we don't want any more
catastrophes but but and you know one of
the things that I do is go around and
visit in areas where there have been
disasters and I go in afterward and one
of the things people consistently say is
that when the flood came when the winds
came - everything was stripped away and
all we had was each other and God that's
it and the truth is that's all we need
each other and God what happens is we
buy into the illusion of life to think
that all this other stuff is what we
need I hope we don't have to wait for
the floods to learn that less well
that's what I'm hoping to this is a
reminder Bishop Corey thank you very
much
you